how did you get the job on idiot test
how did that all transpire I've done a
couple things a game show network over
the years and they've been looking for a
show for me to host and they told me
they were trying to find one and I
really believe it you know you always
your people in Hollywood saying that I
want to find a show for you and then
they actually did they just asked me to
host a run-through in a conference room
of idiot test and I meant before we did
that with the producers and learn the
game and it's a really good fit for my
comedy and for what I like to do and for
my sensibility and it's a really smart
show and I enjoyed that aspect of it and
the conference room run through when
Grant lived here in LA but I was in New
York on vacation I flew back just for 12
hours just to do the run-through and
flew back to my vacation and and it went
amazing and they picked up 40 episodes
for season one right from that run
through they didn't even have it to
pilot after that so it went pretty well
and now we're doing season two so it's
exciting 65 more episodes I'm glad the
show thanks so we I'm sorry did I miss
how did you initially get that like how
did you know that connection did you did
you already audition for something else
for good no just game show network had
just had me I guess they you know became
fans of some of the things I had done
over the years and they had me come in
over the years and and host different
pilots for them and appear as a guest on
some of their shows so the relationship
started that way and they just always
know kept me in mind which I appreciate
it because it worked out in me getting a
show on their network that's a hit
that's fun so then though when that
12-hour like flying there and I heard
you quickly say yes we were setting up
that you love pressure and that you
thrive on it how was that like you're
flying was great I flew you know around
the country on a red-eye left New York I
think it was at 6am and returned at 6am
the next day I was in LA only for 12
hours and I was on no sleep and I had to
do that audition and then go after a
book that there was another audition for
a fox show called weird loners for
scripted acting role that I auditioned
for and then I had to learn both those
and then fly right back and both went
really well and I felt great and I did
not get the scripted Fox show it's going
to be coming out on
anyway though despite the fact they've
mistaken my casting me so that's on them
you know as far as life errors sometime
they have to accept it they have to
explode with that you know that's just
how they're gonna have to move on now
but I got idiot test and yeah I love
pressure to me I can be very lazy if I
don't have a lot going on but when I
take on projects and when I decide to do
things I want 10 things at my shoulders
at once I just smash some reason I just
like a deadline like a hammer being over
my head figuratively I don't want to
hammer on top of my head in life but not
a real hammer well I've heard of that
the certain people like graduate
students or something just thriving on
that deadline whereas if they have a
long time to work on let's say a paper
that they won't do it but knowing that
they have a week left but there's just
some kind of adrenaline rush ok that is
that the same for you like if you know
you have let's say 10 things in the
ether that you're going to be working on
how does that feel that that pressure
because I like in every paper I wrote in
college was I did not read the books all
semester or quarter didn't look at the
work and starting at about 1am the night
before was do I wrote the paper and read
the books and skim the things and every
single one every tests how I studied for
it the ones the papers of my mom didn't
write for me she did write something for
me very much less a nice moment and
that's probably fatal to call cheating
but you know whatever if your mom writes
for I think it's okay I proof read it
sure translated into my own typing you
like the type okays a hand writer nice
the collar and be like mom I cannot read
your writing if you're in my paper
should make you be a little bit more
crisp in your penmanship but it just
feels good I like the pressure right I
enjoy feeling knowing onset that I have
a whole production that's depending on
me to deliver just exciting for me
that's interesting when did you realize
that about yourself because I I realized
the same about myself but it wasn't
until I read this article in like Dino
Psychology Today or something that
people do there's a certain sector of
the population that thrives on that
pressure when was it that you realized
that
I think I realized I think I always knew
that I liked pressure my head there's a
weird conundrum the form because I also
had a pretty severe speech problem
growing up so I couldn't even speak and
I hated the pressure of being called on
for many years of my life I couldn't
even like I didn't want to teach her to
ask me to speak in class so I knew that
I wanted to be an entertainer and a
performer and I can make people laugh
when I was able to speak fluently but
when it wasn't those times I was sitting
there like deathly afraid of being
called on nervous and locked down with
my vocal cords just tense and and frozen
and so it was a weird dichotomy but I
knew that I had to break out of that to
fulfill what I wanted for my life and
eventually I did is that where the being
funny came in because I know a lot of
times people develop that as a coping
mechanism for stuff so is that I don't
think so I don't think it was I mean I
probably helped me be funnier I guess
just you know more so because it forced
me I was a talker as a kid and you know
before I a speech problem came out at
age like three I was talking two million
miles a minute and I found some home
video myself recently and it was like
frightening how fast I was talking and
so I think maybe the world you know
forced me to shut up and listen and
observe and I think that may have helped
my observations of the world and the way
I saw things but I think since I was a
kid I always saw the world in a weird
comedic lens I just would see a
ridiculous thing as adults were doing or
decisions at the world we've making
collectively it seemed and they always
seemed full of folly and they were being
you know decided in a very odd flawed
logic system and so I thought it was you
know if you don't point out the humor of
those things it's just gonna be
maddening so I decided you know I just
didn't slide but it's just naturally
filtered through my brain in a in a
humorous way that's the most boring
answer possible for an answer about how
funny I am well I had another idea
sparked while you were saying that and
that is in those moments when you maybe
had to get up in front of class and you
were dreading maybe the kids around you
and as mean as kids can be how did that
then later groom you for let's say being
on Chelsea Lately or things because you
seem so confident and funny
is that where some of that came from
like yeah a school for you totally you
know growing up around bullies you know
making fun of you for a speech problem
certainly helped prepare me for Chelsea
Handler bullying me on the air in a
friendly way but she made you know a
good part of that show about making fun
of me and everything I would say or do
so I definitely had built up a pretty
strong shield against that kind of thing
and I was able to take it in a way that
I think most people would not enjoy
being made fun of and I loved it and
thrived and so I developed to a point
right you know had such a good sense of
humor about myself i think that i could
just joke about whatever and take it in
a i used to love watching Johnny Carson
and Charles Grodin or Letterman and
groped and argue and growing to be a
guest and it had this contentious energy
but you knew there's a friendship behind
it but it was just this very like
aggressive to me it's just so funny to
have an interview or an interviewee I
angry at each other I just loved that
dynamic I always wanted to do that on TV
so I got to do that yeah I think I think
having having built that up I mean
Chelsea even made fun of my speech
problem on the air a bunch not my Sutter
had overcome that but yeah I slope a
lisp to this day a little bit of a lisp
and she enjoyed putting that out but it
used to be a source of pain it became a
source of humor to me because I realized
you can laugh well of issues we all
things wrong with us it's fun to laugh
at ourselves and she was always able to
laugh at herself to and didn't mind a
few through stuff back at her you know I
always thought that maybe she wouldn't
want that so for the first bunch of
years in the show I wouldn't throw if
the packet and then one day we were
hanging out and I said to her like do
you mind if I sometimes throw stuff at
him sometimes I'm like censoring myself
when I want to throw and sell back your
way except don't know if you'd like it
she's like whoever said you can't throw
something back on me I said well when
you you know have this bravado in the
hallway as an act as though you know you
miss Chelsea Handler walking out there
you kind of give up the impression you
don't want people to be able to throw
stuff back at you as well and she's like
oh that was not my intention i ignore
everybody in the hallways you can say
whatever you want and she meant it and I
started the last couple seasons thrown
stuff back at her and her bandra got so
much better and just so much more
freeing so if you can digitally have to
be able to take it and she certainly
could
I can't do I make fun of people
constantly on idiot test and my stand-up
and on Twitter so if I can't take it
that would be hypocritical I got a lot
of hate these days on Twitter I found
with success you get a much larger
amount of negative responses and people
reacting weirdly to things that you do
and I think it's very funny I often
favorite insults on Twitter I will
engage people that call me idiots like
call people idiots and I'm still fans of
theirs so it would be stupid if I
couldn't you know also you're not doing
anything interesting if you're not
offending annoying some people I think
I've too much my career was worried
about being in offensive or making sure
that I wouldn't you know be doing
anything that was to you know jarring to
any one group and they'll edged and
letting go of so much of that and I
think you know through that comes a lot
of freedom you know the reason I became
a stand-up was George Carlin he's my
favorite comedian ever and I saw some
interview with him and every few months
when I forget this I end up on the
internet down the rabbit hole the
internet and I ki priests tumbling on
this video's interview with George
Carlin were they asked him what made him
surely a success and he said when he
true when we finally stopped caring what
people thought of him is when he truly
started to find success and I'm finding
the same to be true yeah Sam to that
answer going back to being bullied and
feeling may be different in school do
you think that prepared you more so to
get in front of casting directors and
being told well you know you're this
type of you're that type whatever people
are told about who their type is whether
they want to believe it or not and do
you think that helped you because you
know a lot of people realize how thin
their skin is once they get here and
there told certain things and they think
oh I was always told i was this back
home but right i know you grew up here
so but do you think that was a really
good like you'd already had the skin
ripped off yeah I mean I definitely you
need to have a very thick skin to pursue
acting or stand up comedy both you know
both you say I'm comedy you're in front
of people with just your mic and your
word
and auditions you're in front of very
judgmental casting directors who I don't
love the addition process because I
don't think they create an environment
at all analogous to what it's like being
on set and I get the need to create a
pressure situation to see if you can
handle pressure but it's different kinds
of pressure it's negative pressure and
positive pressure and to me that you
know I love pressure on me I'll of
pressure when people are there to listen
are there to know that I'm going to do
what I'm going to do and they're there
to encourage it then that's an energy I
feed off of and so I thrive on asset but
I'm acting on a set or hosting something
on set that's my comfort zone but I
think casting directors miss it all the
time because their audition rooms are
very cold and quiet and just meant old
formulas like hi thanks for coming in
and go ahead and I'm supposed to just
act and just like cold sterile
environment by another judging every
second and every moment to see if I hit
that job the right way sigh you're
supposed to receive entertainment or
receive the performance so I know they
find a lot of good acting that way but I
think they must be missing a lot of good
actors that way as well there's to be a
more fun vibe in an audition room and
you can really see people in their
element confident because when you're on
set yes or time pressure there's money
pressure but there's not a judgmental
energy that I think can affect
performances and I don't even know if I
answered your question at all what I
wanted to talk about was building an
audience on social media and you talked
about Twitter and and sometimes you feed
the trolls and sometimes you don't so
how has it been for you building an
audience on social media and maybe talk
about some of your pet peeves you see
from other performers on social media I
enjoy social media very much I really
love the direct engagement with an
audience at your fingertips any time of
night you know early late sober very not
sober I love that my fingertips I can
just communicate even upload video I'm a
production studio in my pocket you know
so you guys weld set these lights up yet
we could have done it on iphone it would
be some people might like it more am I
like it not as much it's nice to have
production value but the point is it's
amazing that we can communicate in an
instant without any barriers to that
entry anymore
or however it's frustrating a little bit
that I have fun often times that the
smarter stuff tends to get the fewest
retweets and a few as favorites and you
have to often times we really course or
just make a joke about sex or just make
something budget about something very
stupid or mean very overtly mean that
blows up but when you do something more
thoughtful or smart it does not that's
frustrating I guess you know social
media can always be dependent to be the
most thoughtful intelligent folks out
there some are of course they're out
there but you know it's just a little
annoying and then people are little
selfish with it to you know the advent
of the favorite like you people like
something retweet it and then it would
spread it wider and then people discover
the favorites tab they're like oh I can
just click keep that in my favorites I
like it but I don't like it and want to
share it I'm fine keeping this to myself
I like it but just not quite enough so
you get like a great Joe get right out
there you'll get like a lot of favorites
and the small amount of retweets and if
it was the flip you'd be able to
exponentially grow your audience bigger
that's just important because it's very
nice to you're putting your you're all
of your energy into something you're
craving it's nice you get it reached to
as broad an audience as possible so they
can enjoy it and you know get from that
entertainment what you're trying to
create with it you know I don't know how
other comics stick with it when they I
have as much smaller number than
obviously people that have been the
hundreds of thousands and millions of
followers but I don't know comics who
are tweeting and instagramming four
years have like 300 followers or a
thousand followers god blessed them I
don't know how they keep and you have to
you have to make it about the work but
at some point I wonder if you'd feel
like you're talking to just yourself you
know and I hope at least it's climbing
for them you know so i try to retweet
comedians that I respect and enjoy and
follow who or don't have as much
following when I can because I want them
to be exposed to bigger audiences but
you know just not to surpass me it'd be
good if they get just right below my
audience size sure or less anything just
anywhere here especially it's just not
they shot past me would be unpleasant
kidding it so many times of course
haven't many times we've been plenty
people that I helped come up in their
career and gave spots to and
help them get stage time when they were
had no name whatsoever and have shot far
past me as far as Thatcher in the
industry and sometimes they're really
cool and nice and remember that and
sometimes they do not and are really not
so nice about it and it's all good
people can be as they will you just you
know keep it in mind and move on a lot
of times people don't want to talk about
that like oh yeah it's great we're great
friends right but that could be code for
sure we avoid each other in a room I
mean yeah do you find that element now I
mean I guess this is a weird question it
probably shouldn't ask it but yes okay I
mean so you're achieving a new level of
success which is great have you seen a
new way that people have treated you
like maybe the ones that weren't nice to
you before all of a sudden now Oh a been
hey you know we should do lunch or you
know and then the ones that were like
you actually really like them now
they're like more standoffish with you
um yeah you know a little bit not not
bad you know i try to be in my life just
very outgoing and friendly towards
everybody whether they are less
successful than me or more or the same
or somebody i've never met before or
random audience member I think
everybody's the same as of equal value
and and I think that nobody's more
important anybody else we're all
floating on this you know vast
unknowable universe a little bar a
little marble in outer space to think
that the the words of the tasks that I'm
performing a more important than yours
is completely wrong and ridiculous so I
think that amount of that that that
amount of perspective helps you relate
to everybody and I think hopefully I've
been able to avoid that kind of [ __ ]
more than most entertainers for that
reasons I've generally have pretty good
I generally have a pretty good rapport
with people and and I've found that
people just been very happy for the new
level of success I found recently and
generally speaking that is true but I
will say that you know and I think but
you know weirdly I've in the last couple
of weeks had very weird instances with
to comedian friends of mine
were both very good friends and one that
and then both I think just are acting
weird and are seeing things skewed and
in a weird way so you know one of my
former friends and granted we had a
falling out before this happened but we
were had a falling out that was a
respectful falling out and then recently
got drunk at the improv and tore my
picture off the wall and that's
something that you know every comic in
the back their head kind of helps you
want to get picture the wall at the
improv it's like one of the greatest
honors and comedy I think and tore it
off the wall and clearly that's some
kind of weird jealousy or some weird you
know anger or not being able I don't
know what it is United wasn't there and
I'm on the person's head but to doesn't
seem like it's a benign act you know so
someone told you sorry yeah the club
just told me that it happened and
they're working at getting a new one
printed and getting it back up i guess
but so that was pretty weird to fit to
to hear but i think those are anomaly
cases and those those are the times and
the people i think that are I don't know
you know the probably going for their
own things I tried and I try not to take
it to the kind of thing to personally I
don't like the things I don't have to
deal with a lot of it but uh you can't
help but take a little bit personally
because it's you know but it's few and
far between generally speaking people
seem to be very happy and hope they are
behind my back as well but seem to be
very nice and I've always been happy for
other people's success so you'd hope to
mostly get that in return we're at the
Montreal know where the Vancouver Comedy
Festival and I was being seen by a
brillar was the Letterman book of the
time and I did nine minutes of clean
material so there's like two sets back
to back and I had great great set and
Eddie comes backstage and was talking to
me and he tells me this first she works
like Ben you're great at what you do let
me explain to you though why you're a
year or two away from being on Letterman
he'd already said that and then
continues on to compliment the things in
myself that he liked the walks haven't
missed the first two sentences and
missed I did not book the show and was
just in this like angry
like pent-up thing that he then decided
to unload him he gets in my face between
me and Eddie she just here's Eddie
complimenting me and gets in my face and
he goes look at you with your little
cute little jokes your jokes about candy
bars and your little little [ __ ] huh
cuz great for you I must be real nice to
be on the way up on some [ __ ] like that
it was just so weird and unnecessary you
know I've since told him that story and
he apologized for it doesn't matter it's
just a funny story but we end up doing
Chelsea Lately together a few times I
love but people have weird moments you
know I've we had weird moments I'm sure
as well I think it hurts probably a lot
less when it's just some random troll on
twitter or youtube or something that
says something rather than a friend to
rips your photo off a wall and you know
you thought you had some level of a
relationship but but that's that's great
that people have been encouraging i'm
wondering though for your own thoughts
about your career have you ever been
tempted to give up never never so you've
been in la your whole life yeah let me
call a call is in san diego and come
right back never been tempted to give up
everybody probably has a fleeting
thought into their head as much as any
weird fleeting thought but I've never
considered for more than a second if I
would stop doing this it's what I was
supposed to be doing I love to do it it
comes so natural to me bringing a lot of
happiness I've never thought about
stopping it no I thought about shifting
my focus within entertainment two
different forms of comedy or different
types of shows but I've never wanted to
stop I don't think I'll ever stop I'll
be 105 years old doing Sam comedy and
probably doing a web series of some kind
well you have a smart cast right at the
last week on earth yeah and you
interviewed actor Bryan Cranston yeah
and he said to you it's really important
for anyone in the arts do not put all
your eggs in that one basket so how do
you take that advice is that something
it sounds like you have so many things
going on when did you realize that that
advice is how you should pretty much
rule your career well I'd already been
doing that Cranston was right here in
the apartment and did the podcast now is
incredible because he's one of my
favorite actors ever an amazing human
being
break bezel hair show ever so I was just
cool in general to have them on my
podcast but when he said that you don't
apply your eggs in one basket that was
for me was very apropos because I just
started doing the podcast and that was
to me the constant I could give myself
to take the power away from the casting
directors and the people that sometimes
you know or it'll be the gatekeepers of
your success and your happiness so it
was nice to have something that you know
in addition to my stand-up that's just
like could jet self generate and I could
do and help build my fan base with doing
that but I felt really bad lately in the
fact that I've not been able to do the
podcast last few months haven't been
able to find the time I bandwidth has
just been stretched too thin and with a
lot of other things a little bit of life
I have to find time in there as well I
can't always be just creating stuff for
other people and I feel really bad that
I've you know I did the podcast almost
every week for three years and I've not
been doing it so much lately but I will
be doing it again I will be to bring it
back but you know Cranston's advice I've
always understood that I've always
spread myself pretty thin is actually a
problem for me it's I I think I would be
doing better my career if I were focused
on fewer things but I just like it all I
want to do it all and so I just made
peace recently with the fact that's just
in me and it's Who I am and so my career
will go and more of this trajectory
instead of this trajectory but it's
still forward progress here because the
shape ends are going like this kind of
like a whale's tail but forward if the
way of the tables in the front of a
whale and then you can swim forward by
wet you understand sure sure i'm
mentioning the ways the ways of tables
in front and then it would like this and
then the front part you could go like
that yeah and it would propel him
forward even though you wouldn't think
it would it's the point have you seen
other performers put all their eggs in
one basket and how is that different for
you to know that you know what I have my
own show to fall back on it doesn't
matter if someone didn't pick me I pick
me for my show and I picked my guess how
does that work out for you
um yeah you know I just you know God
blessed them it seems when people put
their eggs in one basket off and leads
to very quick big success and monetary
success but I come up with catch phrases
that they push incessantly as punch line
of most of their jokes or you know do
something like that that I don't love
I've never done that myself and I
jokingly will say like I should have the
catchphrase so I could become really
successful but when you put all your
eggs in the basket of One Show or
something that's fine I mean should
always have other projects I think going
that you're passionate about because it
should be shouldn't be about success so
if you have other things that you're
passionate about one more project and
your back burner and your pocket or your
slowly tinkering with as you do your
other thing and that's probably enough
for you I don't think you should ever
take anyone show that you have as the be
all and end all of your career because
shows in as do relationships as do
friendship says do you know they don't
always end but generally they do I meant
that just really for friendships
relationships trills do always in some
point niceeshop sentir to meet the press
relationships do end at some point
somebody dies the worst that the longest
case sure or earlier well but then how
did you start the podcast like what what
was I wanted to do a podcast long time
actually did a podcast you referred
anybody was really doing them I never
released it stupidly and I lost the
files and all these cool podcasts with
great comedians are now really well
known that were in my car was called
glebe drives with and I was with these
different comedians on the way from air
later Irvine I lost them all have like
one or two left at released one on my
smodcast recently with Greg Proops but
then I was had done everybody start
doing podcast I wanted to do one and
then I just random ended up being like
the guest host or co-panelists on this
pilot with kevin smith and and he and i
ended up talking after the show we got
stoned after the show and and he wanted
hear my life story and I told it to him
and at the end of that conference we
were missing the whole wrap party what
we were talking for an hour and he then
the conversation he said to me so what
do you you're a production guy you're a
guy that makes your own things what are
you
doing being here I'm a guest on my show
or on chelsea's panel aren't you gonna
do your own stuff again and it really
inspired me when he said that I already
been thinking that along those lines but
I hadn't didn't have the kick in the ass
to really start doing it and then Kevin
just gave me a kick in the ass he then
said to me you got to come up my podcast
big ass that went to his house and and
he says to me during the first
commercial break do you want to guest
host my podcast here in my house this
friday when I'm out of town I said of
course I do and then the end of the
podcast he said to me do you want your
own show my network and I said yes I do
but I'm torn between these different
podcast ideas I have a format this
interview 1 i've just title i have that
1i have one right cover all the week's
news and it's called last week on earth
and he goes that name is brilliant I
never heard such a good name it's unique
podcast but I'm anything like it that's
the one you should do first and he just
was so decisive and I'm like yeah you
don't say no to Kevin Smith telling you
you should do a show and networking
thinks your titles brilliant so I
started doing it and forward as the
invites i got years ago for my first
manager is Howard Lapidus he said you'll
remember this advice one day and I did
because he said that and sent Matt my
brains remembered probably but he said
forward motion but gets forward motion
and really does just do anything if you
do anything that is something you're
interested in something that feels
productive or creative it will lead to
your next thing either by learning what
you don't want to do but more so it just
puts out in the universe this energy
that's it's an engine you can't stop it
just literally like propels like a
steamship engine that just you know
slowly starts to go and as it starts to
get more water under if this how steam
engines work I've really making that up
I don't know if they do progressively
get faster I've assume seem that gaining
steam is a phrase we've all heard that
hopefully that they're the steam
propeller does not end up running over
the front facing whale tail that somehow
progresses it under the ship on the way
out still know what you can't forget
about the way right whales always under
the water he can't walk so yeah remember
that we whales don't walk no think what
I'm trying to make all right it's flash
she walked she has a mermaid she was a
murderer that's half person half whale I
don't know we're talking about half
people have whales I that was the case
then yes the whale could walk away from
steamships because probably very
dangerous for that motion gaining sure
sure per pet what is
called propeller I think the propeller
it's a wheel also it's a wheel maybe I
don't know how the new boats are but
yeah I wonder if the love boat had that
look if they when they did it probably
felt very exciting you new to them
probably Emily so you've never had sort
of a sit on the couch moment depressed
my life is going nowhere it sounds like
you're just always doing something or
what it lasted like a nanosec yeah I've
had those moments but you end up you
know either having a drink or smoke that
night and decompressing or go and hang
out with a friend or have a minorly
self-destructive night to get it out of
your system or write something the
self-destructive ones never seem to help
you feel great the next day you feel
generally were sore tired but every time
I felt like worthless I felt like I'm
just a piece of [ __ ] that doesn't do
anything anything done the cure for it
every time was when I finally got my ass
and went to a workout room and tried
some new jokes in a small stand-up room
or a big room and just got any time you
try some new jokes and one of them works
every time the weight would just be
lifted off my shoulders I'd be like oh
right the answer is to work and there's
always just to work I mean it sounds so
stupid because it's a corporate slogan
but the most succinct best slogan for
success in life I think is just do it
like you really stole that for shoe and
it's unfair because it's a great slogan
and they say it you sound like an
[ __ ] but I it's a good advice does
something to do with shoes right what
does have to do a shoes any other
follow-up corporate slogan no it's just
just do it it's a great one you've got
mail no it's not really a good life
slogan now you always have mail but
that's just so slow yeah uh but just do
it I mean it's nice nothing to the point
is just nothing to do with shoes sure
just do what the shoe they're telling
you have sex your shoe like what does it
mean out of the context of do something
your life just do it and then choose
unrelated the co-opted brilliance took
it to sell [ __ ] that's a lot of time
what's wrong with the country you got
brilliant moments and then what we do
with that is we turn it into selling
uShip why can't a brilliant moment just
sit alone Billy Joel said it leave a
tender moment alone
let a brilliant moment linger for a
second it's always got to have a slogan
of all these brilliantly inspiring
commercials you know the human condition
then selling your eggs or some [ __ ] like
it's gonna do with eggs not here are
some human eggs if you are admitting of
interesting commercial I would be
apropos mixture of slogan and content
but that's rare you know never fits stay
the Holiday Inn Express recently some
ballin in my life their slogan will stay
inspired it's also good advice they
inspired is very good advice but no
one's inspired were saying and I holiday
inn express it's one of the low bones
it's one of the least inspiring moments
their lives your slogan can't outshoot
your product by a mile that's just very
people aren't gonna buy it I mean maybe
idiots gonna be like oh yeah I'm
inspired here most people are you me
like oh I just remembered how uninspired
I am staying here their slogan should
has been like we're a hotel you can
sleep here right got clean sheets no bet
maybe cleanish there will be a Danish
and plastic in the morning that'll be a
fair slogan I wouldn't criticize that
I'd be happy with that I would not stay
there I wouldn't stay there with a
better slogan neither sinha dopes a web
series that has what four or five
episodes right now for episode where
he's the one okay how did you get
involved in the project Brian drolet
he's the reason I did the show he's a
very funny talented writer and comedic
actor you know we got to start off on
the hillside my perception and people
wouldn't think somebody from the hills
would have a brain or be a real town but
he's really talented very hardworking
guy and he asked me if I would play his
co lead in the show and I wanted to work
with him so instantly I was very
intrigued and pretty much said yes I
said I read the scripts and just make
sure it vibes of what i like and i read
them in he world very funny script but
he also said that he was open to you
know my input on scripts when he said
that I'm axial it up because I've been
really wanting to write something again
I hadn't written my own thing in a very
long time and to collaborate with Brian
we rewrote all the scripts together and
we came out with what I think it's a
very unique funny pretty out of the box
comedy show it's a sitcom for YouTube
it's old-school over-the-top kind of
screwball comedy you'll see a lot of
that you see this
uber subtle sometimes bordering on
boring comedies and this one is just
nuts its out of its mind Brian and I try
to ground it a little bit in our
performances you know but and to allow
some of the rest of the ensemble cast to
go crazy but it's just a funny weird
world we created and it's so odd that so
many weird things have we have a super
villain and we have you know
infestations of crazy animals and we
have people having sex everywhere we
have just like drop me we have we have
popping smoked everywhere it's just it's
a weird Senna dope is a weird fun world
and it's a very good use I think of of
your 15 minutes times four episodes the
people if people will watch and like it
we got to make a season two so everybody
wins we'll see you people watching it
and then us making it again now people
who didn't see it those people lose or
never saw this interview and then those
people are done feel bad for those
people right but they should feel
inspired if they're staying at holiday
and they should did you know was going
to be released on YouTube for free and
what are your thoughts on that that was
cool i didn't understand at first why we
would do that instead of pitching it
around then the team all convinced me
you know that it was an interesting
model that was an emerging model that
people are doing on youtube to you know
not have any corporate influences not
have any bosses telling them network
notes telling them how to tone down
something or fix something or something
they like it if you can make it show
successful you literally can create a
comedy or whatever kind of show you want
that's truly your vision unfettered so
that's nice and that seemed appealing to
me too and a good use of my time if we
could really deliver the way we wanted
to and people received it well then we
get to make more and more seasons and we
could just have this Playhouse to go
nuts in this you know canvas I could go
anywhere so that seemed exciting to me
the challenge is getting enough people
to see it so you can do a second season
because you don't have network money
behind it advertising it's hard spread
the word but hopefully places like film
card you can help good oh wow that's
good I like that then you know what that
should be our catchphrase what do you
think about an actor investing their
money in a project you think that's a
good idea do you think it's it's risky
to invest your own money in the project
but Angeline rolls Troy did it she
funded the sin of dope seat season and
it's amazing thing she had the idea that
she owned the property of this movie
theater comedy and she wanted to make it
and she wanted to do a comedy in an
ensemble and hire other actors give us
all a chance to do a really cool show
and I something that I've rarely done
invest my own money in my own projects
and bested in other people's projects
but not often in my own because I've
always feel like I'm Margot bringing
enough the table when I do my own thing
and I want somebody else to share the
risk with me and so there's more of a
team that is invested but Angeline
really believed and it wanted to put her
own money in it and God bless her for
doing it because when a bad will do it
otherwise so there would be no sin of
dopes without her so it's amazing thing
that she did it and I hope that we gain
enough an audience that she doesn't
regret doing it because it's a funny
show and she's funny in it and the cast
is great and we all worked really hard
on it so it only get better season two
so when you said you've invested in
other projects not your own or not once
that you are featured in what are some
of the key items what is your like due
diligence that you're you know you're
checking up okay all right all right you
know I'll do this what are some of the
things that you look for in those
projects they might you know I have an
invested a ton afraid of thunder where
we haven't invested son of my own money
and other comedic projects i'm currently
perusing whether or not i'm going to
invest in stand-up comedy specials
producing specials further comedians I
just shot mine and didn't do it under my
own banners I don't I want the
validation of another production company
saying if they want me and I want to
give them do that same thing for
somebody else but it's more investing
time of helping somebody taking comics
under your wing bringing comics in the
road that you think of talent and
bringing them out and helping you know
if they just giving them stage time or
any advice if they wanted it about ways
to you know develop material that might
suit them better to help them you know
long to create stuff that might be more
of a of a solid act that can help take
them further in the stand-up world what
it is in people that went out what is I
look for it's just talent
you know I think you obviously can't be
a total fuck-up and have no work ethic
but you can learn a work ethic you can't
really learn talent so I just I just
feel like I've always had a pretty good
I you know I'd finding talent and
knowing when people are good you know
throughout my career I've given untold
thousands of comedy spots to all the up
and coming comedians that people love
now I helped a lot of them you know what
their first spots at major clubs I've
get them into the improv until the
comedy juice shows and help get them
seen by agents and producers ended up
leading to big things for them and I
just only book talent and it's hard to
do that because I don't envy casting
directors have to do that or producers
have to decide who to invest in because
you're putting a lot of money and a lot
of your career and life on the line to
invest in people and so you have to you
just have to pass on people that aren't
talented you have to pass on people who
don't have it and the sad version that
is when people work really really hard
don't have talent that's unfortunate
even but each some work hard working
hard can help can be so affected you and
sometimes they make it through
oftentimes but when someone doesn't have
talent and no organic it's easy to pass
on it's like why why care they don't
even care so you just look for a spark
of you look for people that are
delivering it well delivering a joke
that hits delivering a content piece of
content a short film a painting you're
like wow that looks like it has skill
and uniqueness to it that's what you
look for who were some of the first
people you made laugh was it someone in
your family was a kid at school yeah I'm
sure it's my family I made laugh since I
was a kid my parents my brother my
grandparents and then at school all the
time you know even with my speech
problem i was still on and off able to
speak better different parts of the year
different classes right from work on
flights still one class comedian in
sixth seventh and eighth grade even
though i had a speech problem throughout
all that because i was just still able
to like find funny ways to talk and to
say things and to point out absurdities
and
in other people's behavior and did that
very stammered a weird way often times
but it was always fun making people
laugh at school comedy is a really
interesting defuser of tension it's a
really interesting icebreaker it's a
really great way to you know lubricate a
room Ben glebe five-year 10-year plan
interesting five-year plan idiot test is
completing season seven or eight we do a
couple years sometimes ouran high it
would be great if Sinha dopes was doing
also season 5 or 6 55 years from now
which can be watched by the way at
youtube.com slash total anarchy TV Sinha
dopes a great comedy about it movie
theater sells weed you should watch it
and just doing other things I'd like to
have some move somewhere movies under my
belt some live action acting roles and
I'd like to do in the next couple of
years I have another show on the air
that I on TV that I've that I've sold
that I created I'm a host or actor of in
that I created that really is more my
creative vision I'm I'd like to do all
that together plus bigger stand-up dates
touring theaters I'm always Torian but
bigger venues would be great and the
ability to take a little bit of time off
and that if it's possible and it is not
kind of you can find some time off kind
of flourish and it may be a family oh
okay family well don't think about that
a lot but possibly right next five years
I'm going to do it that's at least be
part of the next 10-year plan most
likely and then ten year plan would be
just you know having just my career
being a way that I'm entertaining as
many people as possible that i'm
reaching a broader audience i don't have
to struggle anymore to get people in the
seats or get eyeballs on the screen two
people are enough trusting and what I
put out there that they just will be
very interested in seeing what I put out
there so that i don't feel like i'm
wasting energy of things i like to do
sometimes i'd love to entertain even
just five people and i always do and i
give a show in front of two people the
same
energy that I give to a show in front of
12,000 people but it just feels better
to do it in front of more people because
you feel like he's made that many more
people happy that day so just bigger
scale of what's going on now I'm very
happy in my life but would be fun to
just be able to do things on a grander
scale what if you have a little Benny
and he wants to be a comic it's all good
with me I'll go with me my parents were
incredibly supportive of me and I
couldn't have done it without their
support I mean they never questioned my
career goals is unusual for parents I
was telling positives and negatives and
I'll let them know that it's hard to do
it but if you want to do it that you
have to stick to it and you can get it
done if you're talented you got to be
honest with yourself but if you have
that talent or not you know if and I'll
burnin somebody from high school that
will you know control show or something
they'll say after the show the love you
like man you're living the dream they
have just like wistfulness and their
voyage they wish they were doing that
and they feel almost almost conveying in
that question like that they are not
living their dream and I think that's
the saddest thing possible because not
everybody is supposed to live their
fantasy dream their childhood I want to
be an astronaut or a comedian or an
actor or a ballplayer dream those
probably most the time are stupid dreams
to continue having once you grow up but
your dream should be the choices you
make your dream should be the life that
you choose because every minute that
banker or that accountant could quit and
pursue comedy if you really want it to
be if that's his dream that's the dream
then do that and if you don't do that
then your dream is not doing that you've
chosen to not do that and it's often a
better choice to not pursue your
passions as your job because then your
job comedy that I loved in my heart
becomes a business you have to figure
out how to tweet in the right time of
day that I get to seem that most
audience and complainin interviews about
not getting enough retweets and all that
kind of thing whereas that guy gets to
just do his job he chose nobly doesn't
help full service to the community or to
the world and then even if that's
cleaning out someone's garbage or
serving them food mcdonalds or whatever
might be those are all very valuable
services and then they get to come home
clock out of that job at five o'clock
and relax in each day's a vacation home
and watch me make it you laugh on TV
because I've been working longer our
friend
great entertainment that takes longer to
create so that's a dream to me I wish
often you know I don't wish I could do
that but I that is an alternate
enjoyable life that I would love to have
done if i did a different style of life
so I just think whatever you do is be
happy with because you can always change
it nice and choice every second we can
change paths any second and so I would
tell them that and also when if I can
just tag on the 10 part of the 10-year
goal is I would like to be in a place
part of why I want to be able to reach
huge audiences there's a lot of things
you can do to impact things to make
change to pack the world these days with
the internet with how fast things travel
you know we've created a high of mind
for Humanity that for species didn't
have a hivemind capability before like
bees or you know certain animals do so I
would love to be able to figure some way
to just help advance the planet in a in
a more significant way whether it's
through a thoughtful show or a
foundation or a charity or something
helping kids with speech problems or
helping solves one big calamity in the
planet or or just you know helping
people have more of a conversation that
leads towards more congruous happy chill
planet that would be very nice and you
need leverage to do that and leverage
comes with broad audience and large
number of eyeballs so I hope I get to
you know like I said I'd like pressure
my shoulder so handle it very well so
the more pressure i get to have I think
the more success and and the more
effective I'll be able to be in my life
so I just really tend your plan just a
lot of pressure on my shoulders but like
good pressure to be you know I'm saying
like good positive steam engine pressure
front facing whale Shin not like
old-school backward moving steam wheel
like old-school traditional whales under
it honey this party been there and done
that no be euphemisms you're talking
about a colony a hive mentality no being
youthful mysm so you can throw on there
no I'm just gonna buzz the [ __ ] out of
people there Tony you know I mean buzz
around and then eat the honey do you
have to get the Adani otherwise what's
the point of all the work well what if
the queen is difficult though Green is
always difficult part of the fun of it